よろしくお願いします
少々の時間 このダンマパダの勉強したいとは思っています
このダンマパダというテキストは
このいろいろところ 短い経典というか
偈ですね 偈って日本語で偈というんですけど
それは詩って歌 歌ですか
ポエムという意味なんですね
ですから この偈でまとめている一つのテキストですが
ある一箇所でお釈迦様が教えたものではなくて
いろんなところで教えたものを短く短く偈にしてまとめているところ
ですから この内容はまあいろいろ内容があります
それからこの一つ一つ独立しています
一つと言っても 時々一つ
時々一つ たまに三つ四つもセットにありますが
基本的には偈一つ一つ
いわゆる四行か六行の偈
一つ一つ独立しているんですね
そういうわけで 勉強する方々にも
ずっとダンマパダ終わりまで聞かなくてはならないということはなくて
偈一つ勉強したとしても
それもしっかりした勉強で
それだけで一つまとめた何か理解することができるようになるんです
まあまあ 途中で来たっても勉強
まあそこからわかると思います
で ずっと全部聞かなくちゃいかんかんということでもないんですね
で まあそれからこの何か勉強する前に
このもうちょっとこの
あの いわゆる客観的に
もうちょっと知識的にというところで勉強した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
知識的な客観的な勉強っていうのは
この まず私が考えていることは紹介した方がいいと思います
私は日本で教育受けたわけじゃないんだから
同じ言葉でも意味が変わっている場合もあります
で 大体主観的に物事を勉強するとかなり腹が立ったりします
自分の意見とは違うことを聞いたりすると
勉強したりすると ものすごく腹が立ったりします
そういう風なことで 自分好きなものしか勉強できなくなっちゃうんですね
やる人にとっては気持ちよくできるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり主観的に勉強すると
いわゆる私が好きなものは勉強する
私の意見に賛成しているものだったら勉強する
私の考え方にちょっと違うものを言うんだったら
あっち行けと聞きたくはないんだという
その態度が主観的という態度なんですね
まあそれ一つの世の中で
大体一般的なその態度では勉強します
で しかし 世の中ではいろんな人がいろんなことを言ってるんです
ですから 全くもう全人類が同じことを言ってるんだぞということはありえないんですね
ですから 他の人が何考えているんでしょうかと
もしも理解したければ
主観で勉強すると勉強できないんですね
ただ喧嘩になって 嫌なことになって
あるいは誤解して終わっちゃうんですね
で その場合はこの言ってる本人が生でいるんだったら
まぁ喧嘩して終わりますが
もし昔の人が言ったことを勉強すると
主観的に その場合は相手がもう死んじゃっていないんだから
もう喧嘩したくても相手がいないんですね
その場合は その相手が言った言葉を自分の主観で解釈する
いわゆる自分の思考で
ものすごい強引にねじ曲げたり解釈したりする
それも世界でこの解釈学ということで
かなり人気のある作業なんですね
古い昔の人々の言葉をどのように理解しようかというと
そのその人が自分の勉強やら知識の立場から解釈したりしますね
それも一つの まあ私から言えば
ちょっとした主観的なことにはなります
で 客観的な勉強っていうのは
まあ Aさんはこのようなことを言う
Bさんはこのようなことを言う
Cさんはこのようなことを言うという風に
この まあ別々に勉強する
それに自分の意見を出して
そこで混乱する必要はないんです
最後に私はこう思いますよと言っても構いません A
さんはこう言う しかし
Aさんの考え方については
私の意見はこういう意見だよと
その場合は そちらにあるのは自分の意見と他人の意見で
別に気持ち悪くなる必要はないのです
なぜそういうことを言いましたかというと
ブッダの教えっていうのは
大げさに言うならば 世間の考え方と世間の高度な知識とはもう全くの反対と言えば反対のことを言っているんですね
そうなると まあ聞きたくはない話になるんですね
私は知っている世界と何で違うことを言っているんですかと
それでどんな人でもブッダが間違っていると
変やと その立場をとって
それ言ったら終わりだから言わないで
ものすごい強引に自分の意見にブッダの意見をとにかく書き換えようと解釈し直そうということに踏ん張るんですよ
現在我々にある仏教っていうのは
その努力の結果なんですね
いろんな人の意見が仏教だと今言っているんですね
だからそれはものすごい強引に
無理やりにブッダの言葉を自分の世界で
自分の妄想の主観の世界で解釈したことになっているんですね
ですから このブッダの仏教は
時代経つと諸子宗教になってしまったんですね
開祖様がいて その人の教えを仏教だというようになるんですね
だから誰かさんが自分知ってる範囲で自分の理解に徹底的に合わせて
まあもうブッダの言葉をものすごくもう調理料理するんですね
料理して全く別な作品を作るんですよ
で それに仏教と言うんですね
この諸子宗教っていうのは
そのような宗教で それで当たり前で
それぞれの先生方のまた意見がまた違うんですね
そうするとブッダと喧嘩してで終わっただけではなくて
互いにもすごく喧嘩することになってしまうんですね
だから仏教の諸宗派の間でも
ずいぶんすごく和合して仲良く同じ仏教ではないかというと
手をつなげてやっているわけじゃないんですね
ものすごい相手の考え方は排他的で
否定してやっている すごい排他的な集まりなんですね
だからそうなっているのは
やっぱり主観で勉強するということになっているんですからなんですね
だから いろんな人の考え方を勉強したいと思うならば
自分の視野が広げたいと思うならば
その人は何を言っているんですかと
どんな論理で どんな理屈で
どんな背景で何を言っているかと
そのまま勉強してみる
また他の人は その人は何を言っているんですかと
その人の教えもそのふうに勉強する
そうすると我々に あらゆる正反対の意見でも勉強できるようになるんじゃないかなと
例えば仏教も勉強してキリスト教も勉強することはできると思います
それは自分の主観でやろうとすると
なかなかできるものじゃない
例えば もともと仏教徒であるならば
もういきなりキリスト教になってくると
神を信じなさいというところから始まりますから
いや これは嫌やということになっちゃうんですね
そうすると勉強できなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 神を信じなさいというところ
なるほど こちらではまず神を信じるというところから始まるんだよと
で それ神っていうのはどういうものか
どのように信じるものでしょうか
そうか そのように淡々と勉強しておけばよろしいんですね
最後に もう自分が信じるかないかというのは
これは別な話で 私はずいぶん
もうまあ 10代で徹底的にキリスト教を勉強した覚えがありまして
教会で用意してあったもうコースというかね
それは全部修了までやってみたんですね
で まあいつでも満点で何でも合格するレポート書こうと言えば
いつでも満点で だからもうかなり立派な卒業証明とかも来ましたけど
で 私にとってはあまりにも単純で
そんなに難しいことではなかったんですけど
最後にこの自分の意見を述べる
何か文章を書いて 論文みたいな形で書いてほしいと
そこでどういうことを項目的に書いてほしいということはいくつかあって
まずあなたは神を信じるかとかね
信じないならば何なのかとかね
で キリスト教勉強したことで
どういう利点とか特典があなたにとってありますかとか
そういうふうなレポートを書きなさいと
私はまず初めに神を信じますかと言われて勉強はしましたけど
神は全くは信じませんと
これから自分の意見を書くところだからね
私は全く信じませんと
信じるぐらいの説得力ある理屈は一つも見当たらなかったと
で なぜかというと あなた方は人を説得したければ
ポイントリストがいたんですよ
こういうこういう こういうポイントを明確に説明しなくちゃいけないんだと
そこら辺説明してくれないと
個人的に信仰するということは無理ですよと
言うと いくつかにはそういうのは信仰すれば済む問題よという答えが出てくるんですね
私はそれを認めて そこら辺までは信仰すれば理解できるものであって
でも最後にこの質問にだけ答えてください
なぜ神は人間を作ったんですかと
で それには答えられないんだから
キリスト教の世界から考えると
そういう答えはないことを私も知っているし
勉強したんだから それで彼らは
それは人間聞く質問ではありませんと
神の領域ですと 神しか知らないということで終わるんですね
それで私はもう厳しい返事を出して
向こうはもういつでも質問してくださいと質問したっても答えられませんだからそれっきり連絡をもうやめましたけど
でも私としては勉強する時は正直に真面目にそれを勉強して
それで自分の個人的な主観ですね
意見を述べなさいと言ったところで言うんであって
自分がもう私が信じてないんだからといって
初めからもうあれはごちゃごちゃ自分の解釈しようとしちゃうと
その教えそのものがわからなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 特に学校でね
仏教を勉強する時でも
先生たちが言ったのは仏教だけ勉強したらもうちょっと弱いんだと
弱いというか 知識としてはね
いろいろ教えをね いろんな宗教やらそういうものを勉強しなくちゃいけないんだと
その時の取るべき態度っていうのは
いきなり怒鳴りつけて
そこは批判しようとではなくて
なぜそういう人々はどういうわけでそういうことを言ってるんでしょうかというところで
そのものがまず理解する
それから比較すると 自分の意見を出すのはまたそれからの話なんですね
まあそこはまあ これ我々のやり方で皆様に押し付けるわけではありませんだけど
あのブッダの教えを勉強する時でも
いきなりこんな意見 私は嫌やとかね
と思っちゃうと勉強できなくなっちゃうんですね
好きやと思ったっても何の意味もないんですね
ブッダがなぜこんなことを言いますかと
それはどういう意味でしょうかと
まず理解しておく それから
それはご自分信仰している宗教と合わないんだったら
それは一人で研究してください
私に聞かないでください
あなたの言ってることは
我々の第何とか何とか君の話に合わないんだと勝手にしてください
それは私の責任ではありません
それを私に聞こうとするんですよ
私の思考というのはものすごい強烈で
もう並みじゃないんです
ですから 私の個人的な批判なんかあっちこっちばらまいたとして
とにかく私の存在そのものを潰そうと思っても
そう簡単には潰せないと思います
そういうこのけしからんやり方ではね
堂々とやってきたら それは力強い人は勝っても弱い人は潰されますけどね
だから何かに強引に私に頼んで批判されてしてもらって
そこをあの人こう言った
あの人はこう言ったっていうことはすごいけしからんやり方なんですね
自分で批判したければ自分でやってくださいと
で 質問すると答えるのは
それは私の性格なんです
質問すると答える 私はとか
それはないんです 私は皆様にたまたま質問するんだけど
全然答えが返ってこないでしょうね
それは私の場合はないんです
質問したらすぐスバリとすぐ尊師に答える
ですから このまあ 自分で判断するべきところは
私に聞かない方が一応安全だなと
私も安全だと思いますし
あの 皆様も安全だと思います
で まあそれはまあ余計な話かもしれませんですが
やっぱりブッダがこう言っている
私がこう思っているという風に
ちゃんと箱をちゃんと別々にしておけばいいんです
で  Aさんが丸い箱を持っているんだ
そんな丸い箱なんか私が嫌だと
そんなのはもう それは Aさんの勝手でしょうに
丸い箱を丸い箱を持っているのは
Bさんが四角い箱を持っていると
それは Bさんの勝手で
自分が箱のことを勉強したければ
Aさんの丸い箱も  Bさんの四角い箱も
Cさんの三角の箱も もう Dさんのオーバル型の箱でも
それは放っておいて それなりに勉強すればいいのです
その箱の進歩はどれぐらいですか？とか
何物でできているんでしょうかとか
取っ手はどういう風に作っているんでしょうかとかね
会社はどんな会社で作っているんでしょうか
それで それ 各箱について勉強する
私は四角い箱は嫌だから勉強しないぞとかね
私は丸い箱が嫌だから
それはもう全然勉強しようとしないと
私はあの会社が作った品物は嫌いだから
その箱については研究しないぞという態度を取っちゃうと
もうそれは勉強できなくなっちゃうんですね
だから自分の好き嫌いはどうでもいいということで
客観的に勉強するという必要があるのです
で なぜそういうことを最初からもう嫌なことを言いますかというと
もともとブッダの元の純粋な教えっていうのは
人間の思考とは同じじゃないんです
同じだと思うのは それはもう思い込みで勘違いなんです
どなたかの日本訳読んだら
これこそ絶対的にスマナサーラパーリ語がわからないぞというふうに思っても
それはちょっとどうかなと私も思います
で どなたかが本を書いちゃうと
その人は自分で理解したものを書くんであって
人間が納得する その簡単に納得できる教えかなと
すごく違うことを言っているんです
ですから ちょっと納得いかないところで
もう怒りに狂っていろいろなことを思っちゃっても
そうするとせっかくの智慧を広げることがなくなってしまうんですね
だからこちらではこの信仰でやっているわけじゃなくて
理性に語っているんです
まあそういうこと 理性さえあれば客観的に勉強するならば
信じるかないか別な話で
実践するかしないか それは個人的な好みで
で 理解ぐらいはできると思います
何か理解しては その点で人っていうのは強いんですよ
理解しないで主観でごちゃごちゃしちゃうと弱くなるだけなんです
ですから 例えばキリスト教は客観的に勉強すると
キリスト教の仲間と堂々と話し合うことができるんですよ
その人とこの人はちゃんと分かっているんだぞと認めてくれるんですよ
その時点で この人間の社会で我々の足場が強くなるんです
何か勉強すると すぐ主観で自分の好みで
もうもう強引にねじ曲がったりしちゃうと
その本家の人々はその人を追い出すんですよ
そうすると勉強しても誰も認めてくれないし
で 弱いんですね そういうことで
勉強してみて できるだけ客観的に勉強してみましょう
それでこの第一章でやるかどうか決まってはなかったんですけど
で この 第1章の第1番目の偈
マノ プッバンガマ ダンマ マノ セッダ マノ マヤ
マナ サチェ パドゥッテナ バサティワ カロティワ
タトーナン ドゥッカ マンヴェティ チャッカンワ ワハト パダン
という三行でできてますね
マノ プッバンガマ ダンマ マノ セッダ マノ マヤ
マナ サチェ パドゥッテナ バサティワ カロティワ
タトーナン ドゥッカ マンヴェティ チャッカンワ ワハト パダン
で で 最初に意味は言います
マノ プッバンガマ マノっていうのは心ということなんですね
プッバンガマっていうのは心が優先ですということなんですね
心が先に走先に歩くんだと
優先ですね 先頭を取っているんです
マノ セッダ 心は優先だけではなくて
マノ セッダ 心が何かに比べるとセッダ優れているんですね
いわゆる親分は心なんですね
頭は セッダっていうのは優れているという意味なんですけど
その一行なんですね マノ プッバンガマ
心は優先で いつでも先頭という
先に心考える と マノ セッダ
心は何かに比べると優先なんですね
というか優れていると
これ何かって何ですかというと
ダンマ ダンマというものと比べてみると
心の方が第一になるんだと
ダンマっていうのは物事という風に一般的にこの場合は解釈するんですね
だから物事はたくさんあるんだからね
世の中に その物事というのは存在
存在で取ってもよろしいし
いかなるものもダンマっていうことに入りますね
ですから全てのものなんですよ
すべてのものの中でマノ プッバンガマ
心が先に先頭を取っているんです
マノ セッダ 誰が偉いかといえば心が偉いんですね
セッダっていうのは偉いという解釈もできます
だから あらゆる物事 あらゆるすべてのものの事の中で先頭を取っているのは心で
偉いのは心だよという考え方なんです
大体この偈で解釈すべきなのは
このダンマというのは何なのかと
それがちょっと難しいんですね
テーラワーダ伝統ではダンマといえば伝統的な解釈ははっきり決まってあって
それを理解するためには
もうまたすごい時間をかけて仏教の世界を理解しておかないとできないんです
テーラワーダの注釈書っていうのは
あっちこっち初心者に読んで理解するために書いているものでは一つもないんです
それはたまたま英訳したんだから
日本訳されたんだから
英訳からもう分かったぞと思っても
一つも 普通に素人に読んで理解する目的で一つも書いてないんです
注釈書っていうのは全て仏教を知っているプロのお坊さんたちのために
その人々に役に立つために書いている本なんですよ
だから一般的に読んでも読んでも
もうすごい だから大学なんかそういうところでは勉強研究できますけど
一生懸命専門的にやってますから
普通わかると思ったら
それはもうそうわからないとは思います
ですから いろんな人が注釈
本書を書きたりして いろいろ理論出したりしますけど
なんで注釈書を書いた仏教徒やらね
そういうことを言うんでしょうかとかね
でもそれはもうあなた方はどう思ったって関係ないと
これは仏教を知っている仏教のプロのためにしている解釈なんです
注釈書って ですから 経典よりも注釈書の方が難しいんです
理解すごい難しい で 論理的に考えれば
注釈書っていうのは経典がわからないんだから
わかりやすくするためのものなんですけど
結局やっているのはそういうことじゃないんです
プロのために書いているんですね
ですから ダンマには注釈書には決まってる意味がありますけど
一般的にどういう意味取るかっていうことは
普通 まあそれはお坊さんたちがね
一般の方々にそれなりにわかりやすく説明する
その時は自分が自分の個人的な意見言わないように
注釈書をすごく気をつけて参考にする
まあそれぐらいのことで
それでダンマって何なのかと
で 私が言った体解釈はもうすべてのもの
もう何でもいいんです
ですから 建物 もうそれもいいんです
それは一つのダンマなんです
では道路は？道路も大丈夫です
ダンマの一つなんです
太陽はもう太陽も大丈夫です
太陽もダンマの一つなんです
だから我々考えるあらゆるもの
何でもいいんですよ すべてのものだから
ものごとだから ダンマという言葉に入るんですよ
では人がもうそんなもう道路とかなんとか言ったって
それは人間作った名前だけではないかと
では私はこれは地球だと思いますよと
もうそれでいいんです
別に 道路なんかあるわけじゃないんではないかと
まああなたは道路なんかあるわけないと思うんだったら
それはそれで構いません
あるのは単なる地球だと思ったら
それはそれでどうぞ でも地球そのものがダンマですよと我々が言うんですね
そこである人が いえ そんな地球と思ったって
これはもう元素でできているものだと
元素っていうのは百いくつかしかないんだと
百いくらとかわからないんですけど
だからこの百ぐらいの元素やと
まあそれで構いません
地球はない 元素ですよと言っても
それはそれで構いません
その元素はダンマなんです
ですからまあそういうふうな態度で取るんです
そこで専門的な解釈は
それどちらにも入らない厳密な解釈で
それはちょっと理解できないと思います
で 時々でも仏教の世界では
例えば心にある感情ってどうしますか？と
心にあるか 例えば嫉妬やら怒りやら憎しみやらね
いろいろ感情があるんですね
その感情はどうしますか？と
感情もダンマですね ですから
わかりやすく理解したいと思うならば
我々に想像できる 理解できる
できない どちらにも関係なく
あらゆるものごと いわゆるすべてのものの中で偉いのは心だよと
だからすべてのものといったら
心もその中に入っているんです
すべてのものだから すべてのものの中に漏れるものはないでしょうに
論理的に考えてください
すべてのもの その中で漏れるものはないんです
その中で心が偉い 偉いというか
ちょっと威張っていると
ちょっと先に走っているんですね
先頭を取っている それで例えば神様を信仰している人は
でも神様は別だよと それはその人は勝手に思うのを言うんだけど
我々は単純な言葉使ってますから
すべてと言えば神様も入っているんです
残念ですけど すべてオールという一切という言葉の中に誰か漏れるわけじゃないんです
ですから 最初から仏教はそういう態度を取っています
例えば他宗教では 人間には尊い魂があるんだよという話があるんですね
そうすると同じではないかと
心 魂は でも魂という言葉を使うと
その人々の思考の中に入って
それは何なのかと理解しなくちゃいけない
ただ無責任で言ってはいけません
そうすると 私は勉強したところで
人には魂はあるし 魂の親分もまたいるんですね
別なところに それには神もいるし
ブラフマンともいうし
アータマンともいろいろ言葉を言うんですね
そういう風に見ると ブッダがおっしゃっているマノ心と魂は同じくならないんですね
なぜならば こちらでは心の親分はないんですね
でも 魂を語る人々の場合は
魂の親分がいるんですよ
その親分の魂の分身なんですね
我々の体にあるのは あると信仰しているのは
あるかどうかは私にはわかりませんですけど
そこら辺でぶつかっちゃうんですよ
合わせちゃうと ですから
仏教で何 だからいつでも世の中の思考とぶつかってしまうんです
世の中の思考を考えちゃうと
すべてのものは神様が立派で支配して偉いという考え方がありまして
日本の神道を見ると もう太陽は神様で
もうもうそれ以上何もないのではないかと
ブッダなんだ ただの人間ではないかという
太陽はもっと偉いんだぞというふうに
そういう立場を取っているし
だからそこでそうやって私が言っていることを正しいと思っちゃうと
仏教と神道はぶつかる可能性はあります
なぜならば 仏教徒はただの太陽ではないかと
仏教はもう太陽も物事の中に入れてるんだから
なんだ下らん太陽ではないかという態度を取っちゃうんです
でも神道から見ると何言うんでしょうかと
はっきりしているのではないかと
太陽のおかげで太陽を乗り越えることできるわけないではないかとか言ったりしますね
だから そういう風に勉強しちゃうとぶつかりますから
別々に勉強して あとから比較してみた方がいいんですね
だからまあ すべての物事の中に心がちょっと威張って
心が先にもう歩いていると
行動していると 心が偉いと
そこでこの最後の語 言葉マノマヤ
マノマヤというのはすごくちょっともう難しい
ダンマパダのこの 1番目の偈はものすごい難しい
それもまあ初めの規範ダンマパダ聞いてものすごく難しくてつまらなかったと思っても
それからすごく簡単です
だからとにかくこの難しい壁を
まあ普通私だったら 1と2は置いておいて
他のところから始まりますけど
で だいたいまあ私が決めるんだったら
これをゲータをすごく再現に入れるんです
かなり仏教を理解したところで
まあマノーマヤという言葉にきます
まあこれ難しいんですけど
ちょっと頑張って理解してください
理解できなくたって構いません
それ 4番目  3番目になってくると簡単です
もう 100番目  150番目になってくると
もういとも簡単な経典たくさんありますから
1 2は難しい とにかく 1行の最後の言葉を見てください
マノーマヤ マノーマヤっていうのは心に作られているっていう意味なんです
心が作っているんだと
想像しているんだと 創造しているんだと
だから物事 すべてのものは結局心のカラクリではないかと
心が作っているものではないかということなんですね
そこで他の教えと比べると
この心イコール神みたいな話なんですよ
何でも心が作ると でもそんなのはお釈迦さんは別に考えていないかもしれませんだけど
まあまあ そんなお釈迦様
別に余計なことは考えたり言ったりはしませんですけど
一応我々強引に解釈しちゃうと
もうなんか神みたいな言葉になっちゃうんですね
もう何でも心に作られているよと
すべては神に作られているよということ
すごいぴったし同じ言葉なんですね
そうすると誰かさんが故に神イコール心やと言ったって
それはその人の考え方であって
だから仏教はそんなこと言ってる
言ってますよと言ったっても
それはちょっと違う 私がそう思いますよと言わなくちゃいけない
で とにかく我々の好き勝手に解釈すると
マノーマヤというのは心が何でも想像して作っているであるならば
我々勉強している他の宗教の教えから見ると
何でも神が作っているんだから
なるほど神の代わりに心という言葉を使っているのではないかと
です故に神イコール心ではないかとというふうに取れる可能性はあるんですが
もうちょっと問題あるんですね
心がどこにあるんでしょうかと
いえば 心っていうのは自分の体の中にある機能について言ってるんだから
そこでちょっと無理が出てくるんですね
神と言えば私ではありませんだからね
神は別な存在で私を作ったものだから
私イコール神にはならないんですね
で 心が心イコール神といったら心がどこにあるかというと
これ己の心について語っているんだからね
自分の心のこと語ってるんですよ
ですから 自分が神ということにはならないんだからね
まあそこでちょっとそういう解釈をちょっと難しくはなります
しかし 仏教で言いたがっているのは
あらゆることは心のカラクリですよと
その心っていうのは自分持っているものなんですね
そこから二行目の話をするんです
そこまで理解しないと二行目には進めないんです
すべてのものは心のカラクリで心が作っているんであると
すべてのものは心が作っているんだと
そうすると原因は心にあるんですよ
で 二行目 マナサーチェパドゥッテーナ
チェというのはもしかするとパドゥッテーナ
汚れた この場合は怒りだと思いますけど
怒りにいろいろもの 汚れた心
汚れた心でバアサティ
喋る 語るは あるいはカロティ
何かをする 汚れた心で喋ったり行動したりすると
どうなるんですかね それで結果は当然わかりますね
心が物事を作るんだから
その心自体がえらく汚れて怒りに狂ってるんだったら
作るものは立派なものにならないんですよ
物事を創造する機関は欠陥だらけだったら
もう作る作品はもう欠陥だらけになっちゃうんです
で まあそれぐらいの単純な意味やと思います
物事を作るのは心ですね
その心がなんか欠陥だらけで
怒りでいろんな欲で汚れて汚れて
もうどうにもならん状態で
でもものは作る まあどこかの食品工場があって
その食品工場でこの衛生管理はほとんど無視
お金かかるんだからということで
全くもう機械洗ったりすることもなく
肉のもう精製やら乳製品のものやら
もういろいろ作って作ってパックしてもう出すと
そうすると全ての品物は汚れているでしょうに
食べてはいけないものでしょうに
それでなんでこの肉食べたらお腹を壊しちゃって
なんでこの牛乳飲んだところお腹を壊したんですかと
なんで下痢になったんですかとか
なんで人が死に中毒で死んだんでしょうかと言えば
工場に原因があるんですね
工場が汚れている そういうことで
工場は私はわかりませんよと
牛乳飲んでお腹を壊したのはあなた悪いんではないかと
あなたのお腹が悪いんだと
これぐらいのことで壊れるもんだからと理屈つけても
まあ原因は心にあるんですね
工場にあるんですね で
ここで言ってるのは全くだいたいほぼ同じことで
心が汚れているならば
心が作るものは全てもう欠陥商品で危険なものになるんですね
そこで三行目の意味になっちゃうんですね
タトーナン それからドゥッカマンレーティ
苦しみがついてくる 苦しみがついてくる
チャッカンワハトーパダン
チャッカンというのは
あの まあ大体この車のの輪のことで
車輪のことなんですけど
一応車にも使います ワハタっていうのは
あの まあ車を引くあの牛か馬のことで
まあ大体牛やと思いますけどね
昔のことだから で この車を牛が引くんですね
ですから まあパダンっていうのは足ですね
牛がもう前に前に前に行くんだけど
いつでもあの車が後ろから来るんですよ
重い荷車が だから牛が足が痛くて痛くて疲れて疲れて走りたいと気持ちあっても走れないんですよ
で これもう例えは別に理解した方がいいんですね
あの あの いっぱい荷物を積んだ車があって
それに牛をつなげておくと
そうすると この牛がこの車を引っ張らなくちゃいけないんですね
昔はあの まあ牛の車か馬の車かね
牛車か馬車かでしたからね
荷物を運ぶ場合は それはテレビでも見て見たこともあると思いますし
時々ロバも使うしね その場合はまあロバはあまり力がないんだから車なんか引けませんね
その場合はもう背中にいっぱい荷物をつけておくんですね
そうすると その動物は歩くたびに
あの重い荷物を運ばなくちゃいけないんですね
離れないんですよ 牛は勝手に私はこの荷車は嫌ですよと
勝手に歩きますよと思ってもできませんね
それは ロバの背中にももういっぱい荷物を入れて
もうきちんと結んでおけば
もうどうにもならんですよ
歩かなくちゃいけないんだから
歩きたくないと言って
もうしゃがみ込んでも荷物は重いんですよ
しゃがみ込んだところで楽っていうことはない
しゃがみ込んじゃったら立ち上がるのはものすごいきついんですね
ロバはよくやりますから
えらい怠け者だから ちょっと歩いて
これは嫌や 荷物重いということで
若者だからしゃがみ込むんですよ
怠け者だから最悪なんです
それから立ち上がらなくちゃいけないんだから
牛はあまりそんなことはしません
どうしても運べない場合はもう倒れちゃいますけど
もう自分でわざとずるいことをしようとはしないんですね
どちらにしたっても この牛はもう奴隷で
もう逃げられない もう束縛されているんですね
自由自在じゃないんです
その荷車 荷車のせいで
そこで汚れた心が物事を汚れた心で喋ったり
話したり 行動したりすると
我々は逃げられないように束縛されて苦しみがずっとついてくるんだよという意味なんです
だから私たちは個人個人では苦しみたくはない
楽しく すごく面白く 楽しく
幸せで生きていきたいんだけど
なかなかそうはうまくいかないんですね
ですから 不幸だと思う人はどこへ逃げても不幸なんです
もう逃げることはできません
どこへ行っても同じパターンで
何なのかというと やっぱりこれはまあ
自分の心がそれを作ったことだからということなんですね
[背景音楽]はい そこでまああの
まあ余計な話かもしれませんですけど
あの 俗世間の考え方はどうでしょうかと
俗世間と言ったって 仏教
ブッダ以外の世界の考え方はどうですかというと
我々の幸福に不幸に原因探してるでしょ
みんな お釈迦様も同じこと
なんで人間は不幸でしょうかと
探しましたし 経済学者も政治家も
みんなもうなんで不幸だろうかということは同じ課題を探しているんですね
だから同じ課題研究しているんですから
同じレポートになるのはいいんですけど
なんか残念ながらレポートだけは違うんですね
研究レポートは ブッダが出す研究レポートはまあまあ心ですよと
すべてのものの中で心が一番偉いんだから
その心が汚れていると
やることを 喋ることはなんだかんだでも不幸になってしまうんですよ
という結論を出してます
それはお釈迦様の長い間の探検の研究の結果なんですね
今言ってるの 結論なんですね
で 例えば政治家の方々に
なんでこんな国が不幸やと言えば
もうあのせいやこのせいやといろいろ言うでしょうね
これは言わないんですね
経済学 経済学者に聞けば
なんで不況不況ですかと言えば
まあこれはもうアメリカの株が値段が下がっているんだからやとかね
というと これはもうアメリカの株売買やってる人々のせいになっちゃうんですね
だからどうすればいいかと
だから私にそんなこと言われて
私はそれだったらこの株売買する人々を脅して
高い値段で買えと 脅すしかないでしょう
脅迫して ニューヨーク株式市場で株売買する人々は
もうみんなもういい加減値段下げるようなことしたら
もうただですみませんと
と脅しちゃえば もしかすると株が高くなるかもしれません
そうすると日本の不況も飛んでしまうと
世の中ではそうやって自分の不幸の原因はいろいろ言ってますよ
時々もう旦那がだらしないんだから自分が不幸やという人もいて
奥さんがもうもうあまりにももう経済的にものものすごい
こう 何というんですか
この もうお金があまりも使いすぎて
浪費家だから あのもう
だからもうダメですよという人もいるし
今の教育システムが悪いんだから
この犯罪の低年齢化になっているんだよとか言う人もいるし
そこで世の中のことを勉強すると
もう複数に原因は出してるんですよ
例えば少年犯罪 犯罪の低年齢化は何なのかというと
まあこれは教育に原因があるんだぞという人もいるし
初志家庭に原因があるんだぞという人もいるし
で まあ日本の社会構造に問題あるんだぞという人もいるし
みんなそれですごい研究して
あらゆる資料やらデータやら持ってきてずっと喋っている
ブッダが何言うかというと
ブッダはもういないんだから
もう新しい解釈はできませんし
これで答え出してるのね
ブッダの研究レポートは
だからどうせ どうせ合わないということをまず理解してください
だから俗世間では外に原因探すんですよ
あなたのせいで私は不幸だよというのは
俗世間の論理で決まってるんです
では嘘でと思うならば調べてみてください
すべての学問 ほとんどの学問は
一応人間は幸福にするために
人間の苦しみって何なのかと調べているところなんですね
まあ医学の考えたってでも
もう不幸 あんた病気になるんだから不幸だと
なんで病気になる？それはまあ
ウィルスのせいだとかね
あいつらをやっつければもう DNA
のせいだ  DNA 今 最近になってきたらDNAやっつけてもう新しく組み替えればいいんじゃないかとかね
それで幸福になるんだぞと
死なないで済むぞとかね
とにかく他人のせいにしているんですよ
だからすべての人類が不幸の原因はあなただよという論理で生きてるんですよ
私ではありません あなたですよと
仏教は いえ 君だよとも言ってないんです
そんなくだらんことを言ってるわけじゃなくて
心だよと言ってるんですね
そういうことだから この一番目の偈にしたっても
俗世間の思考 知識とお釈迦様が自分で仰って仰っている考え方はもう合わないと私は思ってます
で よく俗世間で聞こえる一つの言葉があって
自分を責めるなよと 例えば誰かがこれは私のせいだと
言うと そんなあなたは自分を責める必要ないんだよ
だから自分を責めること自体も
俗世間ではやってはいけないことなんです
だからそういうことだから
ブッダの教えと あの世間の
まあよく分かりますよということは
私はちょっと疑問に思いますよ
本当に分かりますかと
で 私たちは普通はとにかく誰かのせいにしたくなるんですよ
いつでも いかなる場合でも
私が悪くないよという立場で考えたりするのです
ですから これは研究したければ
ずっと我々の人生の中で
どんなものについてあっても
喋ったり話したり時は
自分の心の状況は何なのかと考える時でも
いつでも考えるのは自分が無罪だという立場で考えているのです
子供が不良に走ったって
それで夫婦がそれについて喋っている時でも
父親が自分が無罪だという立場で物事を考えて
母親も私は無罪だと そういう立場で考えた上で話し合ってやっている
話し合いやっています
だから決して結論という答えが出てこないと
仏教の立場から言うのですが
皆様方はもうきちんと解決してるんだぞという立場でとっていますけどもね
世界は そんなのはもうプロに言えばすぐ解決してくれるぞと
仏教の立場は あなた方にはいくら踏ん張っても
絶対どんな問題にも解決法は見つからんと
だからその点でもすごい違うところと立場をとってます
仏教は 例えば教育についても
あらゆるプロたちが集めてガチャガチャいろんなことを何十年も研究して審査やったり
いろんなことをしている
それはもう同じゴミということで
答えではありませんと
だから仏教の実証主義だから
他の研究と同じなんですよ
実証して言うんですね
仏教出すチャレンジは
では人類の歴史を見てくださいと
一度でもあったんですかね
問題解決したことは 例えば夫婦の喧嘩やら
子供の教育の問題やら
何か給料 仕事をして 安心して生活することやら
病気にならないでもう何と何一つ我々なる問題っていうのは政治家
経済学者か医学者が誰かが解決したことがありますかと
例えば平和ということをみんな好きだと言ってますが
みんな平和好きだったら
それ時点で平和でしょうに
どんな人間に聞いたって
あなた平和好きか平和
あるいは戦争好きかと
アンケート取ったら 私は戦争好きな人というのはほとんどゼロやと思いますよ
戦っている人に聞いて
あんた戦争すること好きですかと
いや 嫌ですよと でもこの人々はもう潰さなきゃあかんだからやってるだけ
平和のために戦っているんだと言うんです
であるならば 人類のアンケート取ったならば
全ての人類は平和好きなんでしょう
もしみんな平和好きだったら平和でしょう
単純でしょう だからなんで平和がないんですかね
そっちでなるポイントは
まあ私が平和好きですけど
あなたが悪いんだと あなたのせいで平和がないんだと
私が知ったことではありませんと
そうすると平和を壊す人に対して敵扱いしなくちゃあかんでしょ
そうすると実際の結果は何なのかというと
私が平和好きですけど
みんな平和嫌いやと みんな平和を壊してるんだということで
みんなに対して敵と立ち上がってるんです
だから原因はあなただよと
私ではありませんという立場になってくると
まあこういう風に人類がどう変化したっても
いつでも戦い 戦い 戦い
戦いと 戦えない場合は戦わないだけなんです
戦える時ならば戦うんです
戦えない場合は戦うための準備でもしておくんです
憂いなしと だから憂いなしということは
もう戦えるんだぞということなんですよ
戦えなかったらすごく憂い悲しみがあるんだと
ですが 平和主義です それは俗世間の思考なんですね
ですから ブッダが教えることはもう当然正反対で
しかしブッダの教えは全部商工主義
それで平和のどうというみんなわかる言葉からわかる概念から見ても
人類に平和があった日はなかったんですよ
平和があった日はいつでも何か戦いできてるんですね
ですから もうあなたのせいだ
隣の国のせいだ この考え方のせいだとか
誰の誰のせいやせいやせいやと言ったって
もうじゃあでは潰せば共産主義のせいや
では共産主義潰す 潰したところで平和ですかね
何々もうシステムのせいだって
そのシステムを潰したところで壊したところでもう平和ですかね
だからどう見たっても
どんなシステムが出ても
どんなもう対策をとっても
ないのは平和だけ でも期待しているのは平和ですよ
何のためにやるかというと
平和のためにやる それで得られないものはたった一つ平和なんですね
だから そういう生き方は俗世間の生き方
それはすごい知識的な生き方と俗世間は思ってますけど
仏教はものすごい違うことを言ってるので
それも単純な考え方で言ってるんじゃなくて
これお釈迦様の修行というすごい研究の結果として言ってることなんです
厳密にこの原因を調べて調べて調べていったところで
このあらゆるものの中でこの親分役やってるのは心ではないかと
だったら まあ心の原因があるんだと
残念なことに心というのは私にあるものなんですよ
そこを言うとみんな嫌がっちゃうんですね
それでブッダの話をちょっと解釈してあげようと
お釈迦様に親切にしてくれるんですね
お釈迦様に対して親切じゃなくて
自分の意見に強引に合わせるだけなんですね
それは非学問的なんですね
ブッダの教えを捻じ曲げることは
そのまま理解した方がいいと思います
認めるかないは別 それは個人の好みで
私は嫌いだ それは個人の好みで
でも私は嫌いですけど
その人はこういうことを言ってるんだよと
ということが知識的なんです
ですから 私は解決しないでおくポイントは
全ての物事は本当に心のせいかということは
まあ一応解決しないで置いておく
それはブッダの話が正しいかないかと
皆様がそれなりに研究してみればいいということで
もし別な結論が出たなら私に教えてください
心ではなかったと 原因はどこですか？いえ
裏庭にあった この 何と言いますか
柳の木でしたと なんとか見つけたら言ってください
先生よろしいですか？マノマヤーのところですけども
心が作るというふうに聞いたんですけども
それは対象があって それを感じて概念を作るというふうにお理解してよろしいんですか
神様が人間を作るとか
そういう意味でのおっしゃっているんですか
それはちょっとわからないですね
わからないんじゃなくて
まあ分かってはいるんだけど
まあ簡単にはね 説明できないです
ですから あの 私はもう安全ではなくて
理解しやすくするために単純に理解したらどうですかと
何らかんでも心が作っているんだぞと
理解と納得は別だからね
私は単純に この建物 誰が作ったんですか？ 大工さん
それ正しい答えじゃないんです
それは心が作った  ではないと思いますか？大工でもいいし
私には犬が作ってもいいんですけど
この建物を認識しているのは私なんですけども
その作ったのはこの鉄筋持ってきて人間でしょ
俺の人間に心がなかったらできるんですかね
この人間の心という  結局ボールですよ
心でなくても大丈夫と言えますか
例えば鉄筋を上げたり下げたりするためには
もう手が手が必要やと
どこから手を何かで作って持ってきてください
はい 手 2つありますよ
では作ってください 作ってくれますかね
だからこちらのは この虹
この鉄筋はこれぐらい何メートル
何センチかと これはどんな高さにするかとか
あらゆることを人間の心が考えて
その心が体が動かして
心がその材料を集めてもらって作ってるんですよ
だからこの建物で現れているのは
これは設計した人々の思考そのものなんです
だんだん脱線してくるかもしれないんですけど
じゃあ地球っていうのは私が見ることできるんですけども
地面をですね これは人間の心が作ってくれる
だからそこら辺は我々の認識範囲以外だから
どうにも喋ったっても
ただ脱線するだけで終わっちゃうんですね
ただ このそれまで正しいんだったら
推測でもしかするとそうかもしれませんと言えるかもしれませんよ
でもそれまでは証拠は出せません
はい じゃああの対象があって
それを感じて認識しているというレベルの作っているという意味じゃないということがここに書かれていると
それも心ですけど 対象方認識するでしょ
認識した心が何するんですかね
概念を作る  それから止まる
まあ人にもよるんでしょうけども
そこからこれは立派な建物だとか
いろいろ考えていく  そう思って止まる
そこまで言わない お腹が空くでしょ
お腹が空いたと認識するのは誰？ 自分の心
でしょ それで止まる 私がお腹が空いたと認識して
はい 終わりました  その場合によっていろいろ違うんでしょうけども
いろんなそこに入ってくる条件でいろいろまたそこからの道が変わってくると思いますけども
だから道は変わるんだけど
お腹が空いたらそれで止まらないでしょうに
何かするでしょうに その場合は今日はこの食べ物を食べるぞと
今日は焼いて食べるぞと
煮て食べるぞとか言って材料を調べるわ
持ってくるわ 焼いたり煮たり茹でたりいろんなことをするわ
して食べたりするわ だからその行動は全部誰がやってるんですかね
心で判断しながらやってるんじゃないんですかね
体道具に使ってるだけじゃないんですかね
自分の体使いたくないと思ったら
奥さんに何かラーメン作ってくれとか
言って私の私が作ったもんじゃないよと
もう責任取れませんよ
だから人に頼んだっても
私の心が影響してる  自分の心でしょうに
責任は自分にありますよ
その心と心の問題は確かにわかるんですが
相手が心がないとしますか
その場合は言うことを言ってやってくれない
この時にこちらに来いと言ってみてください
届かないから  この椅子を作っているのはこの椅子と言っちゃいけない
いいえ だからこちらに心がないでしょ
だからこちらに来いと言っても来ないでしょ
もし私がそちらのスイッチ切ってくださいと言ったら切るでしょ
なんで？これがやらないのに
なんでそちらがやるんですかね
心がある  あるからでしょ
だからコンタクト取るのは心とコンタクト取れますよ
そうしますと ここで言ってるのは心のないものは除外してるというマノマヤ
それはもう今我々の今の対話から出てくる結論になりますから
そこまで言っちゃうと仏教が脱線しますから
わかりました  今の結論が我々の対話からできた結論ですよ
それは仏陀から出た結論に私言ってほしいですね
はい あのマノマヤっていうのをマノっていうのは神と
考えようによっては一緒になると言う人もいるかもしれないですけれども
それとは全然違うっていうことは
神はこちら人間の側っていうか
心で左右できませんよね
どうすることもできない存在として
一応認め考えているけど
このマノという場合には
自分で心を清らかにしようと思えばできるし
汚くてもいいよって思えばできるというところで
神と心のは全然違うもんだという風に仏教では考えています
じゃあ仏教はやっぱり全て自分の責任がというポイントだから
あなたの責任と言った途端
神はもうなしってことになるんですよ
全然気にもしない もういるかも
まったくもう もう仏教の世界にはまったくも研究には入らない概念なんです
自分のせいだよと言ったところで
だからちょっとすごくややこしくて
すごい難しくっていうかね
すごい難しいんですね
マノマヤっていうのを定義は
だからこれはもう伝統的に定義するか
もう好き勝手に定義するかってね
いろいろあるんですけどね
もうだからあまり定義しない方がいいんですけどね
本当は マノマヤっていうのは一応心に作られているものやと
安全な小さなレベルで出てくるブッダの答えは
自分の苦しみは結局自分が作ったものだよっていうぐらいのところで十分です
地球はどうしますか？と
放っておけと あんたには関係ないと
M35の星団はどうします？放っておけと
それはもう一応安全なところなんですね
でもあなたの私個人の苦しみについては
これはあなたのせいだから
何とかしたらどうですかと
まあ厳密に言わせると
なんか仏教はそこそこら辺は避けていると思いますけど
まあなんかすごく避けてるんですよ
避けてるんだけど プロにはわかるようにはちゃんと説明はあります
あるんですけど なぜ避けるかというと
この実証して証明を出すことが難しい場合は
まあガチャガチャ言うんではなくて
そこら辺はね 証明出せる出せないものは置いておくんですよ
だからじりじりと証明出せるものを堂々と言う
で 真理はあるんだけど
すべてのものに真理には証明出せるかないかっていうことは難しいんですよ
まあ例えば月に裏側ありますよと
まああるんですけど では見ましょうと
あるんだったら でも見えませんね
どう踏ん張っても ですから
地球の裏側のクレーターのことやらことはもう喋らないで
もう知らんと置いた方がいくらか安全
知らんということはないということにはならないんですね
あるんだけど 知る方法がないんだと
あることだけはなんとなく確かなんですね
ですから あることは確かなんですけど
証明出せないものはだいたい初期仏教ではもうあまり説明しないんですね
そこまで考えちゃうと
あなた方は困るだけだと
あなた方は単純な問題を忘れるんだ
単純ではなくて 重大な問題を忘れるんだと
君が苦しんでいるんだよと
君が死にかけてるんだよと
だからあなたに治療することはもう優先で先決だよと
ということで あのあの毒矢の話は
あなたいろんな変な説明もありますが
経典で出てくる話は ある人がね
森で矢に刺されちゃって
それで毒矢なんですけど
死にかけているんですね
そうすると親戚が慌てて早くこの矢を抜けて
この人に治療しようと思っちゃ
その人はちょっと待ってくださいと
この矢は鉄でできているか木でできているかと
まず調べてくださいと
それで木と言ったっても
どんな木ですかと それから
だから矢に先っぽにつけるあの鉄分は
あの棘の部分は それはどんな金属でできているんですかと
それにそれにつけているあの毒はどんな成分ですかと
調べてくださいと それ調べない限りは矢を抜くのはやめましょうと
やめなさいと あるいは売った人がバラモン族の人か
シャトリエ族の人か あるいはワイシャ族の人か
シュードラ族の人かと
ちゃんと情報を持ってこいと
でないと この矢は絶対あなた方にそう簡単に無責任で抜くことは許せませんと言うと
その人は死んじゃいますよと
で その例えでお釈迦様が何言うかというと
彼が一つも答えがない質問を聞いているわけじゃないんです
全てに答えがある この矢はどんな木でできているんでしょうかという
これは確かなものだから答えがあるんですよ
毒はどういう毒作っているかと
使っているかと それは確かに答えがある
売ったのもそれはやっぱり豚がね
弓で撃てませんだから
これ人間だからね で 人間売ったことは確かなんですね
それでインドの話だから
インド人は四つのカーストに分けていることも確かでしょうし
ですから 売った人は何カーストの人かという答えが確実にあるんです
あるんだけど放っておくしかないでしょうね
そんなのは 知ってどうするんですかと
だから智慧のある人はすぐどうでもいいんだから
すぐ矢を抜いて薬をつけて治療するんだと
だから病気治せばいいんじゃないか
死なないで済めばいいんじゃないかと
あなたの苦しみがなくせばいいんじゃないかと
そうすると では治してから調べればって
別に治してから調べたって泣くってどうでもいいでしょう
ですから 治してからも悟った人々は調べません
そういう余計なことは
答えあるんだぞということを知ってますけど
興味ない 興味あるのはもうものすごい現実的な問題についてなんですね
ですから 仏教ではこの宇宙のことやらあんなことはもう考えるなよと
もうそんなのは それから心の働きについても考えるなよと
必要なものを教えているんだから
それ以上考えちゃうと頭狂っちゃいますよと
宇宙は無限で理解しにくいもんだから
同時に心は無限で理解しにくいものなんですよ
なぜならば心が親分だからね
全てのものの中で物質よりは先だからね
だから今の思想の中でも
やっぱり心の中にあるのは
やっぱり物質はすごい巨大で偉いんではないかという概念があるんですよ
だから だから地球はどうしますかとかね
地球なんかの管理 心できるわけないではないかという立場
それは俗世間の思考なんですよ
でも ここから見ればそうじゃなくて
あらゆる物事の中で心が親分で優先で
もう威張ってるんだったら
宇宙なんか物質でしょうに
心が威張っているのはもう当然なんで
この外から見ると でも我々は物質が偉いと思っているんだから
我々にとっては本当かなという疑問が出てきます
それも当たり前 だから言ったんです
最初からもう私たちの思考から見れば
なんか本当かなというね
違うんじゃないかと という疑問が現れます
ですから それはそれでいいんです
疑問があっても ですから
別々にしてまず理解する
私たちはやっぱり物質の方が偉いと思ってますけど
ブッダはそうじゃないと言ってるんだよと
ですから ブッダによると
大宇宙よりも心の方が威張ってるみたいんだよと
全部管理してるみたいだよと
という風に理解した方がいいんです
そうすると 地球作るのも太陽作るのも
宇宙作るのも心になるんです
その宇宙の変化からもう何から何までも
結局は裏に心が隠れ隠れているんです
裏ではなくて それは心の命令で変化していくんです
心の希望で そこまでは人間にはいくら踏ん張っても理解できないところなんです
理解しようとしたっても
これはもう答えがあるんですよ
発見する方法もありますけど
発見してどうするんですかと
それを先にあんた死ぬんだよということでね
ですから あんたの問題をまず解決しなさいと
疑問 dacă ありづらい
あれはもう用なしになっちゃうんです
で そういう説明はもう一応ありますよ
普通の人にはなんとなくわからないようにと
堂々と書いてますけどね
宇宙がの変化論は仏教で書いてますから
そこでヒンドゥー世界と一般人が知ってる言葉使ってるんですね
お釈迦様 本当に知っていた宇宙論は言ってないんです
言っても理解してくれないんだから
だって地球は丸いと言ったところ
それだけでお釈迦様笑われちゃいますからね
ですから それは言わないで
あまり混乱起きないように気をつけて
一応語ってはいるんです
宇宙っていうのはこの地水火風の働きによって壊れてしまいますよと
地水火風というのは素粒子レベルの働きだよっていうことは
当時の人々に分かったもんじゃないでしょうに
だからみんな普通の土ではないか
普通の火ではないかと思っちゃうんですよ
だからお釈迦様が言っていることは
我々は全く別な概念で理解する
例えば水で地球破壊すると
ある水という素粒子なんですよ
だから素粒子が分解して素粒子になったら宇宙がないんだから
もう元素もないんだから
素粒子っていうのはもうものすごい理解しにくい
もうものすごい怪しいタチが悪いものでしょうに
で お釈迦様がそれでもう水の問題で
まあ全部もう消えて消えていくんだよと
どこまで消えるかというと
梵天のところら辺まである梵天のところがあって
そこまでなくなるんだよと
それで梵天と言ったっても
みんな考えてるのはこの洪水で
自分住んでいるこの四角じゃなくて
この平らの地面が洪水で消えるだろうと
だから水があまりにも高くて
梵天のどこかまで上るんだよと思ったっても成り立たん話で
そんなのは でも仏教でも別に水で
ある日は水で壊れる ある日は火で壊れる
ある日は風で壊れるとかね
風で壊れる場合は このアカニッタとか何とかという梵天があって
この最高のところ そこまで壊れてしまいますよと
風っていうのは素粒子の場合はこの引き離せる素粒子なんですよ
引き離すものなんです
だからものは引き離して引き離すと
全て引き離して もう分解して消えてしまうでしょうに
罪というのは引き寄せるエネルギーだから
全部ギューッと収縮することなんです
このことは こんな地球なんかはちいっと縮んじゃったらね
もう目に見えぬ埃一つにならんならんでしょうに
ですから そこを言っても誰が理解するんですか？今現在我々にも理解できんでしょうね
素粒子の働きは それをお釈迦様はうまく
まあまあ 適当に理解してくださいということで
別にどうってことないんだから
もう修行して悟ればいいんだから
まあまあ適当に理解してくれても
あの まあこんなもう宇宙はうんぬんとかね
考えるのはそんなのはもう長い長い長い年月行ったところで
こういう風に壊れちゃいますよと
で 壊れたらこの生命はある一箇所にもう固まるんだよと
生命というのは心でしょう
だから物質の中にガチャガチャやっていた心は
物質が分解すると  別なところにエネルギーとして固まったりして
エネルギーとしていうのはちょっとおかしいんですけど
それからやっぱり心がどんどんやっぱりまたまた物質欲しくなってくると
どんどん構成していくんだと
それでこの人間の業によってっていうこと
人間ではなくて 心の業によってまた現れちゃいますよと
そこは私がこの個人の心と
あの 皆の心というのを 2つに分けて理解しようと努力するんですね
個人の場合は 私の心で私が病気になるか
元気になるかというのは私一人の心では十分ですが
この日本全国を豊かにしようと思ったら
みんなで心を合わせてくれないとダメではないかと
私一人で もういくら踏ん張っても無理ではないかと
ですから 心と心はとっても簡単にコンタクトするでしょう
この椅子においでくださいと言っても全然来ないし
人間に言ったら一言葉ですぐ来るでしょうに
まあ妄想してるんだから一言葉で来ないんですけど
一応妄想を破るまで何回も言うと
ああなるほど 目が覚めて
ああ 呼ばれているんだそうと
だから来ますからね 勉強できても理解できても
それは妄想のせいだから寝ているので
妄想イコール寝ていることなんですよ
だから時間がかかるんですね
これちょっとこっち来てくださいと言っても
あっち向いて上見てそれ私ですかと
それで目が覚めて それ時間かかります
一応コンタクトできることだけは確かなんですね
妄想さえなければ 人間というのはものすごい速いんですよ
ものすごい速い 寿命はすごく伸びる
で まぁいろいろ仏教では理解
今までまだまだ理解できないところたくさんあります
例えば人間の平均寿命は
仏教はもう万単位で万年単位で計算するんだから
でも  1万年の寿命の人っていうのは
我々は知ったことはまるっきりないでしょうし
もうあと 20年かなね
平均寿命は 100ぐらいになるんだよというふうに
イギリスの発表ありましたけどね
平均寿命はものずっと伸びっぱなしだと
今生まれる子供は これから 10年ぐらい生まれる子供の場合は
もう平均寿命は 100になるんだと
まだまだ 100で計算する
ブッダの時代でも 100で思っていましたし
平均寿命は当時の では
仏教の論理から見れば
人間の寿命はまあ軽々くもう 100万とか何とか軽々く飛んじゃいますね
ということは 今の我々は人間の DNA にもその能力はあるんだということなんです
では なんで早くする？ DNA の中にいっぱい汚れがあるでしょうね
DNA の中にも なんで汚れが入り込んじゃうと
心が汚れてるからなんですよ
ですから 母親の父親の何とかで生命が生まれるかもしれませんだけど
そこで心のエネルギーでどんな DNA 組み合わせるかと
これは何万通も組み合わせありますよ
その中でこんな組み合わせやと思っちゃうと
それでもうもうもう死ぬまでこの荷車運ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから 心の性っていうことにしているんです
因果律っていうのは心の法則っていうことなんですか？ 因果律は心の法則で
物質の法則にも因果は当てはまります
法則だからどちらでも当てはまりますけど
ブッダは心の法則だけはおっしゃって
たまたま物質の法則もたまたま言ったところはあります
だから 気候の変わり目で雨が降ったり
乾季になったり エルニーニョ現象を起こしたりすることも因果法則ですけど
物質の因果法則はすごいわかりやすい
心の法則はわかりにくい
仏教の因果律はもう確実に心の法則
そこで最終的には仏教はナーマとルーパと物質の 2つに分けて
ナーマっていうのはあの
お坊さんたちが最近何か別な解釈をしているみたいですけど
まあ伝統的な解釈はナーマっていうのは心であると
ルーパっていうのは物質であると
その全てのものはこの 2つでできているんだよと
ナーマとルーパ 心と物質
そのたらこり それで ある物質はの中で徹底的に心は機能していて
ある物質にはもう客観的に機能する
例えばこの物質にも心が働いているんだけど
客観的に働いたんだからね
作った人は外の物質をいじったであって
使う我々も それをもう使ったりすることも客観的に心が働いていることなんですね
この机は 1 ミリでも動かした動いたならば
これは誰かの心なんですね
それでまあ地震が起きて滑ったと言えば
それは明らかに物質的な法則で
それは誰もあまり不思議には思いません
ですから それは客観的な働きで
でも自分の体の場合も
まあ客観的な働きもありますしね
薬飲んだり運動したりする場合はね
でも 心がずっと中に入り込んじゃって
体そのものは好き勝手に変化する
それは我々のどうすることもできないところもあります
それは心は自分で自由自在にやってやっているんであって
客観的なところは管理できます
例えばちょっと足が弱いなと分かったら
毎日散歩でもすれば 客観的なところでまあ強くなってきたりする
基本的なシステムは変えることはできません
もう諦めるしかない そういうわけで
牛の車繋げたら牛にはどうすることもできない
運ぶしかないんだから
この荷車をね その苦しみを味わいなくちゃいけないんだと
で 仏教としてはもう簡単ですよ
私の背がこれぐらい伸びているのも
あるいは私はあまりにも痩せ痩せているのも
あるいは体重が過ぎているのも
もう髪の毛がないのも
あるのも もう全部もう心がやった仕業やと
どこかで管理不可能なところはありますよ
今の好みで 例えば世の中を見ると
180センチ以上の人は格好いいやと
ある時は勝手に決めると
そんな世界が勝手に基準を決めちゃうと
こちらにはじゃあでは 180以上に 190 になりそうと思ったってできんでしょうね
そうすると私がもう背が短くて
もうかっこ悪いなとかね
落ち込んだりしたりしますしね
それはもうもう心が決めたもので
自分では管理できません
また ある時期になって
人間の好みというのはえらく変わっちゃいますから
やっぱり 160 は一番かっこいいやと
170 はかっこ悪いやと決めちゃうと
175 センチの人がまたすみません
本当に足が長くて申し訳ないと思っちゃうんですね
だから人間いろいろ好き勝手に好みが変えちゃいますよ
女性 例えば昔は女性というのはいくらか男性よりは体が大きくて
あった まあなんて言いますかね
大きいんですけど それで何か最近になって
ことえらい痩せて なんかもう空気が強く降ったって倒れるぐらい
病気でなきゃあかんと
体力もなく病気な体だったらすごいかっこいい
それでみんなもうダイエットしたり
もう無理な運動したり
体いかに壊せればいいかと頑張っちゃいますけど
そう簡単にはうまくいかないんですけどね
それでまたある時期で
やっぱり体がすいたった方がかっこいいやと決めて付けたら
また頑張る ずっと痩せた体だったら
もう遺伝的にもどんどんもうみんなもう骨だらけになるでしょうに
そうするとまたもう体重つけるためにまた何かやらなくちゃあかん
だから好みっていうのは時代的に変わりますが
どこかで我々の管理に我々の手が届かないところっていうのはどこかではない
はっきりあるんですね
例えば 自分の思考パターン変えてみようとかね
ほとんど問題は思考パターンでしょ
私は不幸だ 仕事をできないんだ
自信がないんだとかね
能力がないんだとかね
人と喋るとうまくいかないんだとかね
それ全て思考でしょうに
思考さえ変えればもう簡単に済む問題ですけど
でもそう簡単には思考は変えてくれないんですね
それで我々はこの自分で救う作る足が高く欲しければ高くする
短く欲しければ短くするという風に
今では時々高く高い椅子が欲しい
時々短い椅子が欲しいと思ったら調整できる椅子を作ったりしますでしょ
それでみんな椅子の調整できるんだけど
なんで自分がもうちょっと白くなりたいなとか
もうちょっと赤み赤い色になりたいなと思ってもそうならないんでしょうかねとかね
もっと髪の毛がいっぱいあった方がいいなとかね
赤い髪がいい 欲しいなと思ってそうならないんですね
その時は あ これは神様に決めたと平気で決めちゃう
決めるんですよ それは神の領域やと
仏教はそれも心の領域だと
もうあんた奴隷やと もうどうにもならんやと
心が作ったもんだよ だからまあ心の勝手で動いてやる
で 文句言わずにもうまあ頑張りなさいというようなことなんですね
病弱の体に生まれたらもういい加減にしなさいと
別に文句言わないで どうにもならんでしょうね
心がやったことだから
例えば ものすごい食欲ばっかしの人々いるでしょ
あれは本当にかわいそうやと思いますけど
まあもう炊飯器でも2つご飯炊いても全部食べてまた食べられるんだと言っちゃうと
まあ大変だと思いますけど
でもその人にしたらどうにもならんことでね
で 不幸になるんですよ
そこでほんのちょっとでも食べられない
ちょっと食べてもお腹壊す人いるでしょ
でも食べられない お腹が
そうすると食べるものがなくなっちゃう
食べるものなくなっちゃっても体が壊れるんだから
栄養を入れなくちゃいけない
どうやって入れればいいかとも方法もない
それでまた不幸になってしまうんでしょうに
だから あらゆる面で人間っていうのはそういうふうなことはある
それは神様だと思い込んだ途端
仏教から見ればへりくつなんですよ
なんでそんな残酷なことをするんですかね
ある人はもうみんなびっくり
腰が抜けるほど美しくて
他の大勢の人々はもうものすごい
もうどうでもいい状態に作ったりとかね
だからなんでかとね 採算いっぱいあって子供ができてたまらん人がいるんだけど
なかなか子供がいないし
自分でも食べるご飯ご飯食べられないのに
子供が8人いる 10人いるとかね
神様に授けるんだ なんで神という貧しい家庭を狙って
子供を作るんですかね
そうすると平気で言うで
その人々はこのバースコントロールを正しくやってないんだと
では それ正しければ 金持ちの人々も一生懸命あらゆる治療を受けたりするでしょう
子供を作るために 子供欲しい人は
だったら生まれてくるはずでしょうに
時々子供がいなかったら国にも問題が起こる場合もあるでしょうに
誰かとは言いませんんだけど
で 何でしょうかね それで神様と言っちゃうと不公平ですよ
いい加減な言い方っていうのは
論理的じゃないんですよ
だったら神は善人よりは悪人ということが言った方がよろしいし
だって世の中でももう100万人 1000
万人に一人しか幸福で何でも揃ってる人がいないんだから
体もすごい美しくて もう体力ももう体力ももう何でも揃って
家族は幸せで頭も良くて
これって問題ない人っていうのはもう1000万人に一人もないぐらいだからね
ですから やっぱり仏教は心だよと言ったところで
何の不公平もない正しい原理だと思います
だからバラバラだと 心はどうせ汚れているもんだから
まあ幸福よりは不幸の数が多いっていうのはよくわかるでしょうに
どんな人間の心を調べてみたっても
もう怒り 貪り 欲やらもう嫉妬
憎しみ もう競争心 それしかできてないでしょうに
人格って何なのかっていうと
憎しむこと 嫉妬すること
落ち込むこと 舞い上がること
そんなもんでしょうに
欲張ること 怒ること だから心が汚れているということは当たり前だから
まあ億人の人を調べたら
楽しげな人は一人二人見つかったぞという数字がありますよ
きっちりと そういうことで
心が汚れたならば不幸になるんだと
逃げで言っているのは
心が綺麗であるならば幸福になるんだよ
いわゆる生きること楽だよと
その時使っている例えは
チャーヤーワ アナパーイニ
あの逃げの一番最後 チャーヤーワ アナパーイニ
自分を離さない影のように
アン アパーイニ アナ アパーイニ
アンナ アナパーイニっていうのは離れていかない
逃げていかない 自分の影はどこに行ってもついてくるんです
でしょ？逃げていかないんですね
でも影持ち運ぶのはすごく重い
影っていうのは足からついているもんだからね
足かせのように感じたことはありますかね
すごく楽でしょうに 影っていうのは
そういうふうに楽に生きていられるんだと
で 荷車がついてくるちゃうと
また楽ってわけじゃないんですね
そこで最終的にこちらで言っているのは
心が汚れたら喋らん方がいい
何もしない方がいいということ
危険だと 心が綺麗だったら喋ってもよろしいし
何かしちゃってもいいんですよ
それでこの心という問題で理解できんところはどういうところかというと
我々は心と言ったところを言うと
あの 何を思いますかね
この考える知識だと思うんですよ
認識だと だから本当かなとわからなくなっちゃうんですよ
心っていうのは 認識は心の一つの働きなんですよ
この働き このある特定の働きのみが心というわけじゃないんです
そこら辺ではすごく難しいというかね
どうせ我々人間だから
あれが綺麗 これが綺麗じゃないとか
そうやって考える思考がありますね
今日はちょっと寒いとかね
昨日は雨が降ったんだけど
今日は 雨が降ってないとかね
でも午後になると降るかもしれませんとかね
そういう風に考える機能が私の心だと思ってるんですね
それはもうほんのわずかな一部なんです
それも心です 明らかに
でもそれのみ心というわけじゃないんです
で それは大胆に理解してもらうために
私が言うのはもう心臓が
あの 鼓動しているのはあなたの意思でやってますよと
それわからないでしょ？えっ
それは無意識的だとすぐ言っちゃうでしょうに
でも意思ですよ あれも
それで知識でやってる
やってないわけだけは確かなんですね
でも私が生きてるんだから死にたくないでしょうに
生きてるんだ 死にたくないという気持ちはどこにあるんですかね
まあたまたま死の恐怖感がある時だけ表に出るんであって
本当はずっと持ってますよ
ずっと怯えてるんです
だから心臓がすごく怯えてる
だから必死になって動いてるんです
だから あの 興奮したら
興奮したら あるいは驚いたら
びっくりしたら ものすごいドキンドキンと
動くでしょう  肛門も尿道もそうだと思うんですね
すごいショックを受けた時に
人間が失禁するとかっていうのもあります
普段は肛門もお行儀よく閉まってるっていうのは我々は認識できないと思います
でもある時見える時が
力が抜けちゃうという
ものすごく恐怖が 全部もう機能し
機能しなくなっちゃうんですね
その時は単なる物体になって物質法則になっちゃうんです
だから全ての細胞はね
心で動かしてるんです
例えば怪我したら 怪我治る
別に自分の心が治してるとしても
それはわからんです なんか理解もできんでしょうに
あ 摩訶不思議やと 細胞が働いてくれてちゃんと治してくれるんだよと思ってるだけなんですか
仏教は心ですよという
だから私理解してほしいのは心と
仏教で心というのは この
あれが綺麗 これが今日は寒いというふうに思う思考だけじゃないんだよということなんです
なんかこの思考で管理できんところもありますね
それはナームとして取っている心なんですね
この煩悩に関わるあるのはね
この無意識な心は まあ煩悩を基本的に持っているだけで
これは刺激して引き起こすのはこの五感の情報なんですね
五感から情報入ると もう刺激で煩悩が引き起こして
また立ち上がって また新しくエネルギーをつけて
また無意識のところでじっとなっちゃうんだから
だからこの五感のところで修行して
煩悩を引き起こすんではなくて
もうもう根底からもう殺してしまうと
それで解脱できるということになっているんですね
そこそんなところですけど
1と2はものすごい難しい
で しかし これで一つの独立した教えなんですね
これだけでも仏教の全体を理解できます
ある程度で 我々は気をつけるべきやと
心が汚れたらすぐキャッチするべきやと
心が汚れたら ずっと綺麗になるまでそうとした方がいいんですよ
何したっても良くないんだと
で 俗世間見てください
全ての行動は汚れた心でやってますよ
貪瞋痴で 学校に行くのも
勉強するのも もう仕事に行くのも
何でももう貪瞋痴なんですね
むさぼりか怒りか何とかとか
本当は良くないことをやってます
で でもやらなくちゃアカンってことやってます
だからこそ いくら頑張っても納得いく結果がないんですよ
必死で仕事をしたんだからといって
最終的には無に終わっちゃうんですね
何かつまらない 何か納得いかない
必死で勉強したんだからといって
ああ よかった やったぞと
そういう満足の結果がないんですよ
何をしたっても この世の中で全て何か虚しく終わるんですよ
あるいはこんなはずではなかったっていうことになるんですよ
頑張って頑張って総理大臣になっても
何かどこかで自分で納得いかないっていうかね
失敗ばっかりで ということはあるんですね
総理でない場合 私 総理になったらこうするそう
こうするそうと思ってはいるんだけど
なってみたら何一つもできないと
それは思考がもともと悪いんだからなんですね
今の現代状況を見ると
ただ面白おかしく喋ればいいというね
他人のことだったら面白おかしく批判することできるんだけど
それは自分のことになったら批判するだけで終わりませんだからね
何かやらなくちゃあかんだからね
人のことって あんたそんなことやったらダメですよ
なんかバカなことするんじゃない
こういう風にするべきではないかと偉そうなこと言えるんですけど
自分でやるときは それは自分がやらなくちゃいけないことになっても
また他人になんか言って
うまいこと言ったそうと思ったっても
もううまくいかないんですね
誰かがやってくれるでしょうということで
だから結局納得いかんですよ
だから我々はお金がないんだから言って金持ちになったっても
どこでこんなはずではなかったっていうことは必ずあるはずなんです
だから この世の中で満足ということは成り立たないんですよ
勉強しても もう何しか仕事をしても
ただ生きていて 年取ってもうボロボロ
死にたくない 死にたくないと泣き叫んでわめいて死ぬ
怯えて それは王様であろうがホームレスであろうが関係なく
みんな同じことで なんかすごいかわいそうなんですね
といえば もうホームレスの方がかっこいいということになっちゃ
何も頑張ってないんだからね
でも その人は納得いかない人生で終わる
世界 1 億万長者になってなった人も納得いかないで死ぬと
どちらでも不満なんですね
私は頑張ったのに なんかいろいろトラブルばっかり
あと あの昔 すごい大金持ちのアルフレッドオナシスという人が
ケネディ大統領のお子さんと結婚したでしょ
あのジャクリーンケネディという人と
で アルフレッドはその時世界一の億万長者でね
オナシスは それで彼が考えたのは
世界一お金はあるんだけど
世界一立場がない 財力あるんだけど
人気やら有名やらね そこはないと
ステータスはないと それでケネディの家族っていうのは
もうアメリカではね もうものすごい尊敬されている
まぁ神様 王様みたいなね
家だから 人間の感情で見れば
その人でも結婚すれば
その人はケネディ家じゃないんですけど
ジャクリーンと結婚すると
それで人気者には世界的に
だから我々もこの人の名前を知っているのは
ジャクリーンケネディのおかげなんです
とにかく でなきゃ誰も知りませんだからね
で 億万長者世界一億万長者は結婚したのはしたんだけど
あの人のお金の使い方には頭が痛みたい
[笑い]厳しく制限しなくちゃいけないことまで行ったんですよ
買い物の病気は 例えば何か服が何か気に入って
服はいいんですけど このネックレスやらこの宝石とかね
これいったらこの店で
その会社で作るものは全部まとめて買うと
服の場合でも全部もうまとめて自分で買うと
なんで全部買うんだよ
でなきゃ同じものを他の人が着るんだと
そこまで金使い ですから
結局は普通の家庭でもね
あんたあれ買ってこれ買ってどうするんですかと
普通の男たちも困ったりするでしょう